yeah and i when i was younger
uh my mom had told me that she used
heroin my dad used heroin she told me
she told me
and i didn't understand it then she said
you know over everything i would give
i would give you up and your little
brother up for drugs i would choose
drugs over you and your brother your mom
told me
yeah and she didn't mean not to be to be
mean or or anything like that
it's just the way drugs are
all right josh josh uh where'd you grow
up where are you from originally
um from south jersey right outside of
camden ten minute about ten minutes from
north philly kensington
so kensington is another community
similar to skid row right
yeah it's about just about the same he's
open air drug marketing there's a lot of
homeless people everywhere
yeah how would you compare the two um
there's a lot of there are a lot of
drugs out there you know you get a drug
on any block you can't even walk down
the street without being offered
whatever you want
basically so and honestly it's oasis for
a gigantic thing
yeah and then the police tend to leave
you like yeah i didn't leave you alone
you don't really get bothered out there
right yeah
and how was your childhood um
i'd say like i didn't grow up with my
mom or my boss they both you know both
addicted to drugs
and they're in and out of prison so i
grew up my grandfather raised me i was
getting a lot of trouble
you know on probation at a young age and
uh getting
you know foster care on like um
committed programs and stuff like that
uh therapeutic communities and and juvie
um i just i i acted up a lot you know i
got into drugs young
just like everybody else in jersey you
know but um
you know just i thought it was just what
we did it's in my blood everybody does
it
you know that was normal how was your
childhood
i'd say like with your family and all
that
my grandfather raised me in my it wasn't
like he didn't show emotion so i wasn't
like really connected
to them you know i was more like i felt
separate
you know so your mom and dad didn't
raise you no no no they were in and out
of prison
you know so i did i know them you know
i i just never lived with them i'd never
seen them together
they got locked up when i was really
young so my dad's still in prison right
now
but um you know my mom uses drugs still
but i i knew her a lot know her very
well you know
she um she's been homeless all over the
country she saw me
she like kind of like hit me like just
taught me how to um basically how to be
homeless and how to
appreciate people and treat people when
you're homeless and
just how to survive that's that's what
you've been you've been living on the
streets for how long
um i've been on my own since i was
basically 14 and out of programs since
17 is
when i got off of probation and started
traveling the country went out to
colorado see my mom's
ended up in foster care and after that i
ended up living on the streets in denver
and um caught a charge right after i
turned 18
and i went on the run so i started
working at a carnival in texas my mom
hooked me up with them
to basically travel with the carnival
and like
off paper so i could was on the run from
the cops basically
and there's like it's like living on the
streets there um
and we ended up back in denver and uh
it's just cold
it's too cold out there you know i
almost died from just
just freezing to death you know it's a
foot of snow on the ground you just like
you have to you have to get high you
have to drink you have to do something
to stay warm
you can't sleep at night because you're
shivering so bad yeah part of the reason
i think skid row is so
populated is because it's a climate that
you can deal with
for a lot of these people you can make
it to la then you can just survive on
skid row and
yeah i mean everyone including the
police leave you alone oh yeah
it's like like i said it's same as
kensington
you offer whatever you want it's not
hard to find you know all my
i know a lot of people from out of state
that come out here and this is where
they go
you know um like i come out here every
day
you know like i got a lot of people out
here i got a lot of friends out here
you know what's your drug now um i do
fentanyl every day
every single day and crack every day a
lot of it
um what do you what do you spend a day
on
um me and my fiance go to about a half
ounce
in two three days quarter hours a day
maybe
a fentanyl and that's how much um
well i mean i get pretty good prices on
it because i sell drugs a little bit
um so anywhere from like get it from
like
an eight ball for 200 a quarter ounce
for like
anywhere from like 250 but i usually get
like a half pounds for 500
600 people try to charge a lot more than
that but
um i mean it's really prevalent out here
i got pretty decent plugs on it
but it's just it's just a lot you know
there's a lot of people that have it a
lot of people that do it
but we do too much
we do entirely too much have you ever
did yeah i've always did
i will do a few times in my life first
time i was i was 18 years old i was
doing heroin in philly and i overdosed
on that doing shots heroin
um on a bag because they'd stamped their
bags out there it's called good luck
it was called good luck
yeah when i was in a coma after that one
went to a coma i had pneumonia in the
hospital
they nearly killed me i was in a temple
lung center in philly
like really bad pneumonia after that
you know i've um tried getting sober a
lot a lot of times i came out here to
california to
go to rehab just like you know a lot of
other people that are from out of state
you know it's just uh is that what
brought you here yeah yeah that's what
brought me here i know a lot of people
out here that came out here for that
and um i really wanted to be sober a lot
of times i really thought it like that
was the answer but
and it is you know with always with a
lot of respect like
eventually that has to come but right
now i've been doing doing fentanyl every
day for
more than a year and i'm actually scared
yeah last night it was the first time
i've been
been without for as long as i've been
without and it was like
because i've been i've been able to get
it every day you know
i've been i was so sick last night
but you couldn't get it last night
because why so it's not like i didn't
have the money for it's just like nobody
was responding
and i had yes nobody was responding it
was but
i fell asleep all your connections were
yeah
yeah i i lost i lost uh my last phone
and i lost my girl's phone so i'll
contact her that's all your all your
contacts were gone yeah and i just lost
an ipad out here
on skid row yeah you lose things on a
daily basis out here yeah i actually
absolutely do
absolutely do and living on the streets
i mean that lifestyle works for you
honestly for a certain amount of time i
enjoy it because it's not like
because that's all i knew you know since
a young age and i was either in in
institutions or on the streets you know
i didn't know how to live a regular life
go to work every day pay your bills that
type of stuff
you know since i came out here to
california after getting sober for a
while i
started living that but um you know
and for me my friends i don't want that
for us but i can't i could go back on
the streets in an instant because
it's it's what you're used to is what
you know yeah
having a life with responsibility and
bills and and
rent and all these kind of things does
it kind of scare you of it
it not only scares me i don't i don't
know if i can manage yet
you know i mean i've been doing it all
right
but it's the drugs always everything
goes away yeah everything will go away
everything
we have booked up for so long it all
does it all goes away and then
you know this is ground zero this is
where you end up every single time
no matter what you think you'll end up
spending the rest of your life on
in this kind of situation um well i i
don't i'm not lucky enough to kill
to die from using fentanyl because you
know just
like once you build a tolerance you know
just don't overdose anymore
you know no matter how you try it
doesn't work
oh really so because your body has built
a tolerance to it you can
do more and more of it yeah i mean you
just do a lot i mean
there's always a chance that like you'll
do the one shot that'll kill you
but it is is there a high still from
doing fentanyl
for a while there there isn't but
there's like different types of fentanyl
there's car phenol and there's a regular
fat in the dark burning stuff
and that's more like a body eye it lasts
a little bit longer not really get high
from it but
you just need it i need i feel well from
it but the car fit not knocks you out
you know i'll knock you out
but um no i'm not really scared
of it anymore like i used to used to me
you know and there's times that i don't
i i've almost i probably black out every
night
like if i stay up for a couple days like
i won't know how i i'll go to sleep
me and my fiancee will pass out and it's
like we're blacking out at the end of
the night it's just just
passing out from straight exhaustion you
know and when i wake up in
a weird spot like head between our legs
you know
on the ground laying with my dog
you know butt sticking up in the air and
weird spots man it's not it's not safe
it's not okay
but it's the life i'm used to and how
are you
i'm 25 25 no kids no no kids okay
yeah i've been uh i'm using drugs since
i was since i was young i'm
shooting up since i was 18.
heroin pcp crack i've done it all acid
you know what do you worry about really
worry about what do you worry about yeah
um biggest thing i worry about is is my
fiance
you know and trying to make her happy
and do what i can
to keep her okay
you know i worry about it is it
difficult
maintaining a relationship a romantic
one where you're
once you become a hardcore addict your
priorities change right
yeah you know getting the fix becomes
like your first priority right
no it's true it's totally true because
you know we
you know we've been blessed to where
we've been able to get it every day
but there's that the moment in time when
like
that [ __ ] comes first i talk to so many
addicts who
will give up their kids their health
their life
their jobs their careers everything
because the
the fix is more important yeah and i
when i was younger my mom had told me
that she was she used heroin my dad used
heroin she told me she told me
and i didn't understand it then she said
you know over everything i would give
i would give you up and your little
brother up for drugs i would choose
drugs over you and your brother your mom
told me
yeah and she didn't mean not to be to be
mean or or anything like that
it's just the way drugs are yeah you
would choose a drug over anything
you know as strong as my morals as i
want my morals to be
as strong as i as i want my to maintain
my responsibilities and values
eventually they go away eventually drugs
come first
and then you stop taking like my health
is my house is filthy
you know and i'm a clean person i'm neat
i like to be neat i like red meat messy
bed messy head to my mouth my house is
filthy
piss dog piss on the ground sink full of
[ __ ]
it's embarrassing i really should have
said that but like
just um yeah just don't drop something
first sometimes
yeah then you're a young man where do
you see your life going like you're 25
what do you think you'll be 35 45 do you
have any goals you have anything you
i have tons of goals tons of aspirations
still i'm glad i still do
because there's certain points in time
where i was going to kill myself
you know i've tried you know just
i didn't see hope at all but you know i
see hope
you know if i can kick this [ __ ]
hopefully
or try to maintain it better which never
works and i have goals i have
aspirations i like to go to college
you know and my girl just tried opening
up a business
you know doing um like rehoming uh
fashion products like bags and belts and
stuff like that
book bags you know we're trying we're
trying to do something
with our lives you know but we we slack
on it
all because they're drugs basically jobs
are coming away
seems to me like the trap that drug
addiction becomes
is you know you start the drug for
whatever reason you know
trying to forget about childhood traumas
or whatever
but eventually it changes your brain
chemistry where you no longer have the
wherewithal to
to to resist the drug you get addicted
and
you just there's you can't fight it any
longer i can't
yeah i can't i've heard so many heroin
addicts say i'd rather die than quit
it's scary i'm so scared to [ __ ] stop
using fentanyl
i'm so scared because i i use it every
single day all day long
i've never been without last night was
the first night
and then your brain chemistry gets so
altered that you can't
you don't have what it takes to fight it
any longer no that's alright
any longer that's all i could think
about how the [ __ ] am i gonna get it
and your day revolves around it every
day well every day
everybody's what i do every day you have
to wake up in the morning and have it
ready for you oh yeah
me and her wake each other up and he's
like here here's this and here's this
crack and finish
it you have to set it up for that track
infinity yep crack and fitting
don't wake up without it
what does crack do for you um
crap keeps me awake enough to manage you
know
because like i honestly
i with the fetty what you do is you lose
you're feeling a pleasure you don't feel
pleasure anymore from anything
and crack gives you that [ __ ]
endorphin rush that that
that's a pleasure that's my pleasure you
know
but then there's a certain point where
you just do it all day long
constantly like right now i don't i
don't wait this long to take crackers i
take crackers
i don't even breathe almost that's how
much i smell crack it's
kind of scary it's only because i've
been really blessed to be in a situation
i'm in
but um i'm feeling afraid right now like
i'm
i gotta go at some point you know i like
to sit here and talk like this is
i know i'm gonna talk about this stuff
for people i don't get to be honest
about this stuff to people you know
because it's embarrassing yeah and i i
might not look
i probably do now but like i can i can
hold my own
in a conversation most of the time but
at this point i'm getting strung out
you know is shame a big part of your
what your experience go yeah
you know you know i try not to intervene
in most people's eyes try to stay away
from people
trying not to like but if you had kids
and then they were being raised by your
mom or grandparent or something like
that then there's that shame on top of
the other shame
yeah i i don't know if i could have kids
because i can't do that
to my kids like my fam my mom and dad
did that to me you know
i could i couldn't i would do the same
thing they didn't [ __ ] continue to
use
it just becomes a trap yeah what's the
most important lesson you've learned
the most important lesson i've learned
is
you just can't use that one time that
first time
the first time if you think it's okay
you can just can control it
you think it's gonna be different it's
not
it ends up here every single time and
hands it back here every single time i
thought i had my [ __ ] together i thought
i had a place i thought
the bends and i thought crash the bends
you know
maybe about to lose the place and here i
am on skid row
all right josh thank you so much for
sharing your story thanks man i wish you
the best of luck
yeah thank you thank you very much
you